c'est un problème je fais maintenant des
dizaines d'années en de dizaines
d'années que j'ai 20 ans ces jeux vidéo
ça reprenons l'histoire depuis le début
lucas hochart et les jeux vidéo c'est
quoi lorsqu'il était petit lucas
découvrir les jeux vidéo grâce à son
grand frère florent il jouait à tekken
sur ps1 mais vu que le jeu était violent
leur maman adorée cacher le jeu pour les
faire chier plus tard le cas découvrit
le site de jeux flash absolue flash
il y passa de nombreuses heures il
découvrit ensuite counter strike 1.6
prix dofus qui lui pris une bonne partie
de son existence
hélas certains se souviendront ça ça
comment c'est arrivé cette cicatrice la
belle cicatrice là là vous savez
sûrement je jouais à dofus j'étais en
plein combat
mais mon horaire de pc c'etait de 18h à
19h et mon frère c'était 19 heures à 20
heures il était à 9h05 et mon frère on
me mettait la pression pour je lui lâche
le pc ce qui est normal mais je voulais
terminer ce combat contre des prêts ce
pic pour drop et ma coiffe dupré speak
puceau ayant 40 10 minutes sur le temps
de pc de mon frère celui-ci fut pris de
rage et et thenia le pc de force
et voilà qu'est ce que je fais j'ai 12
ans j'ai bu vie commence à pousser à aa
j'ai frappé dans un cadrage et 20 points
de suture première fois de ma vie que je
rage au point de blesser physiquement
des années plus tard blésa ressorti un
nouveau jeu vidéo qui révolutionna la
vie de squeeze overweight
les amis aux vosges fait cette vidéo on
est lundi il est actuellement 13h10 j'ai
passé le pire week-end jeu vidéo ludique
de ma vie j'en ai les larmes aux yeux
quand j'en parle pas encore mais ça va
monter c'est bon vous connaissez
forcément overall jeune homme et je vais
vous expliquer un petit peu le système
de classement au goût du vin rouge tu
peux faire des parties classées et selon
ton niveau tu vas pas retenir une
certaine catégorie bronze argent or
platine diamants m grand maître mégalo
il est là bon je suis un connard mickeal
o'conner d'opter dans ta catégorie tu
joues tu essaies de passer dans la
catégorie du dessus en gagnant plus de
parti possible dès que tu en perds tu
perds des points donc tu risque même de
passer dans celle d'en dessous bref
c'est terrible et au bout de deux ou
trois mois la saison se termine ça veut
dire que tous les rangs sont remis à
zéro il ya une courte pause d'une
semaine ou deux et nouvelle saison
commence hélas et les gaines de
placement tu fais dix parties et il faut
regagner le plus possible pour atterrit
directement dans l'une des catégories
s'il admet que génitales heure là ça
permet de départager les gens des débuts
la saison si vous voulez en gros le mec
a perdu toutes ses gammes il se retrouve
en bronze avec les autres mecs ont perdu
tout leur game qui ont donc le niveau
des bronzes le mec a tout gagné se
retrouvent diamant ou mètres et se
retrouve avec les mecs pour tout gagner
et qui se retrouvent diamants m aussi
bref voilà ça mais les nus la clé de
l'effort avec les formes et les normaux
avec les normaux c'est là qu'un problème
intervient je fais mégane de placement
jeu try hard au point de saigner d'une
arme couche en faisant des une fois là
quand on touche une étoile est née avant
de dormir tellement j'avais saignée de
rage ouanna le manga et saigne du nez
quand on les voit des filles sexy moi je
saigne du nez qu'on joue un jeu vidéo
et quand je vois une fille sexy je meurs
je fais ma première gamme de placements
et c'est une grosse défaite c'est la
première j'en abuse tranquille et là je
n'avais jamais vécu ça avant une série
de victoires monga squeeze tu fais et
les victoires j'ai eu plus de mal à
faire cette victoire qu'à voir 7
millions d'abonnés ma deuxième game je
la gagne ma troisième guen je la gagne
ma 4ème game je la gagne la cinquième je
fais une petite égalité voilà si jeanne
game je la gagne 7 mbia jack and with
schengen ja gagne et de l'anarchie plus
parce que j'étais tellement excité que
mémoire elle s est éteinte je me dis
donc que je vais atterrir dans la
catégorie diamant l avantage de la
catégorie diamant quand tu atteins donc
3000 points c'est que si tu repasses en
dessous des 3000 tu restes diamant et à
la fin de la saison tour en est un
diamant tu gagneras beaucoup de points
de cote qui permettent d'acheter une
arme en norme kikoolol qui brille de
partout flambant neuf au total côté
moudjeb pechstein
accrochez vous bien à vos testicules the
pop avec une cote de 2 1988 à 12 points
du diamant sachant que quand tu gagnes
une game a prêté game de classement tu
gagnes 40 points de cote
autant dire j'étais un poil de cul du
diamant et là je fais la game qui
m'auraient permis d'atteindre le nirvana
des plus excité car ouistiti devant midi
les ou la 11e game ça s'est mal passé je
redescends à 2968 de côtes
si je gagne cette deuxième partie
organes de classement je passe diamant
c'est la cover watchmen amy winehouse
m'a regardé dans les yeux et m'a dit
aïcha el nono achètent des skins fils de
[ __ ] ma cote est descendu à 2948 il
fallait maintenant deux victoires deux
victoires pour pouvoir passer diamants
mais deux victoires dans une vie c'est
quoi c'est quoi après deux défaites les
probabilités font que si tu perds deux
fois tu vas gagner deux fois je perds la
troisième guerre
vers la quatrième je perds la cinquième
guen je perds la 6e game jeu qu'à la
septième gay je perds la huitième game
je perds à neuvième gain je perds est
10ème game je perds la 11e gain je
pleure force rider parler ça me tente
moi j'ai envie de frapper un cadre je le
ferai pas parce que j'ai dofus si je
vais vous illustrer ce avec des
figurines je vous dirai ça c'est ma tête
juste après les gammes de placement
après avoir fait cette victoire sur 10
km et pensait atterrir dans la catégorie
diamant ça c'est moi en voyant que j'ai
atterri dans la catégorie platine avec
une cote de 2 1988 et que je suis passé
à un chouia du diamant et ça c'est moi
après les [ __ ] de 11 défaites
d'affilée vos potes les amis je suis un
gros et deux sur les jeux vidéo mais
surtout les jeux vidéo ou c'est en
équipe pas le jeu vidéo où tu es seul
par exemple leur stone où je passe
starcraft même si joues pas tu es seul
tu peux compter que sur toi même si tu
perds tu perds c'est que tu es nul je
suis un [ __ ] de et ne soit jeux vidéo
et j'ai envie j'ai envie qu'un
traitement existent comme un patchs à la
nicotine quand arrête de fumer un patch
en tirages sur le jeu vidéo pour juste
s'amuser de se dire mais la défaite
c'est quoi c'est pas grave on est là
pour s'amuser on n'est pas là pour
gagner mais qui habille cette phrase un
jour c'est fort je vous avoue c'est
insupportable en 2016 les jeux
comment dire à plusieurs parce que comme
dans ton équipe quelque chose ne va pas
et tu dis à la personne n'était pas très
fort et que ces persos prend plutôt lui
si tu échoues avec ce sera mieux et que
le mec se braque et même t'insulte mes
voies de fait avec moi comme d'un
conseil jeudi bas mec merci tu as raison
je fais pas tu insultes et de dire je
suis fort que toi c'est débile et là on
dirait une vieille merde tu fais une
vidéo pour supporter le poids de 11
défaites d'affilée et c'est exactement
le cas si la manne en tout qui joue
funny games us tome je vais parages et
parce que c'est un joueur 1 contre 1
après c'est facile de mettre la faute
sur les autres de dire à ce bon équipe
qui était nulle c'est pas moi non
moi je la mets quand une grosse paire
avec schengen pour himer ça se voit à la
fin tu as pas de médaille d'or dans
watchmen médaille pas mérite pas mérite
pas de skill j'aimerais aujourd'hui
qu'on fasse une sorte de junkie damas
que tout le monde est vraiment l'air
comme ça devant son pc et se tape la
honte devant la maman qui pas air est
emmené au large et envoyez moi votre
énergie pour ne plus rager devant les
jeux vidéo je la ressens oh oui je la
ressens je la reçois un peu trop oh mon
dieu c'est trop bon petit corps
c'est un jour tomber avec moi dans une
partie de la watch mon pseudo et squeeze
mais plein de gens peuvent avoir le même
se donne donc sera pas forcément moi
même si c'est un autre un kaka pas de
vie qui veulent copier qui veulent être
nul comme moi sur au vin rouge et vin
soyez doux et gentil avec lui prenait
l'eau par la main et il vous prendra
part le bras merci de m'avoir écouté
n'oubliez pas vive la france vive la
démocratie
et vive la république merci
noël mon équipe a été nulle au sila